How the Modern Calendar Came to Be
Perfecting a method of foretelling and predicting
the passage of time preoccupied our ancestors
from the earliest recorded history.
The unending journey of the Sun, Moon and
stars across the great expanse of the sky
provides clues for numerous methods of marking
time, the most obvious to primitive man being
the passage of a day (light/dark) and that
of a month (based on phases of the Moon).
Measuring the exact length of a year is difficult,
but for our ancient ancestors’ less stringent
parameters, such as when a certain tree would
bloom, was sufficient proof to denote the
beginning of a new year.
The ancient Egyptians knew that to calculate
an accurate measurement of a year, it was
necessary to take note of where the stars
are in the sky at any given time.
Specifically, the priests of Egypt used Sirius,
the Dog Star, to predict the flooding of the
Nile annually, which gave them the appearance
of being able to foretell this event.
Studying Sirius also enabled the Egyptians
to become the first civilization to switch
from a lunar to a solar calendar.
The ancient Babylonians utilized a lunar calendar.
Even today, the Muslim and Jewish calendars
remain lunar-based.
Nice, if you like tradition, but using a lunar
calendar poses a major problem as well.
A lunar month is 29.5 days, meaning 12 lunar
months add up to 354 lunar days, which is
about 11 days short of a solar year.
To solve this problem, some lunar calendars
add an extra month every now and then to make
up for lost time, which is how it is handled
with the Jewish calendar.
However, the Egyptian priests’ study of
Sirius allowed them to count the exact number
of days in a solar year.
They then arranged the lunar months into 12
month intervals, making each of them 30 days
in length with five added days at the end
of the year.
Sounds pretty good, but there is a problem,
which is that every four years Sirius shows
up a day late.
The reason for this is that the solar year
is really closer to 365 days and six hours,
which the Egyptians never took into account,
though they were aware of the issue.
This resulted in the calendar taking a backward
slide as a lunar one would do, only at a much
slower pace.
By the time of the Roman Empire under Julius
Caesar, the calendar, which was out of sync
by about three months, was in desperate need
of tweaking.
With the help of Sosigenes, a renowned astronomer
from Alexandria, Julius Caesar started a new
calendar on January 1, 45 B.C.- a calendar
that came closer to the solar year than any
of its predecessors and became known as the
“Julian Calendar”.
Sosigenes informed Caesar that the actual
length of the solar year is 365 days and six
hours, as the Egyptian priests had known.
Sosigenes felt the logical solution was to
simply add a day to February, the shortest
of the Roman months, every fourth year.
This made up the difference, and with this
clever idea the leap year was born.
This calendar quickly spread across the entire
Roman Empire, and was also used throughout
Christendom for centuries.
And yet, once again, an error popped up.
It turns out, that the solar year isn’t
actually 365 days and six hours after all.
It’s actually 365 days, 5 hours, 48 minutes
and 46 seconds.
This only amounts to a discrepancy of a single
day over 130 years, but when you’re talking
millennia you have no choice but to nitpick.
By the 1500s, the seemingly minor glitch of
calculating the solar year to be 11 minutes
and 14 seconds shorter than it is led to about
a 10 day gap between the calendar and the
real solar year.
This posed a particular problem around the
equinoxes, which were occurring 10 days earlier
than the dates on the calendar denoted they
should be.
Clearly something needed to be done, so Pope
Gregory XIII asked Christopher Clavius, a
Jesuit astronomer, to help him solve the problem.
Quickly discovering that the error in question
amounts to 3 days over a span of 400 years,
he devised a brilliant solution to the predicament.
The ingenious astronomer put forth the suggestion
that years ending in ’00 should from that
point on only be leap years if they could
be divided by 400.
By doing so, three leap years are eradicated
every three centuries, providing a tidy solution
to the problem.
The proposal, named after the Pope responsible
for hiring its mastermind (rather than the
mastermind), was put into use in the Papal
States in 1582.
The Gregorian calendar was quickly picked
up by Spain, Portugal, France and the Italian
states the following year.
This was a time of great religious upheaval
in Europe, and many of the Protestant states
were in no great rush to concede that the
Bishop of Rome was right about anything.
The Lutheran states of Germany finally got
around to making the change in 1700, while
Great Britain put it off until 1752.
Even though by that point Britain had accrued
a sizable gap of 11 days, many people protested
violently when the change was made.
Russia did not convert to the Gregorian calendar
until after the Russian Revolution in 1917.
(The funny thing was, in 1908, the Russian
Olympic team arrived 12 days late to the London
Olympics because of it.)
Further technological advances in the 20th
century made it possible to hone the accuracy
of the Gregorian calendar even more.
For instance, it has been suggested that to
fix a small error in the Gregorian calendar,
one day should be added every 3,323 years,
and years divisible by the number 4000 will
not be leap years.
So, the next time you’re scribbling down
your dental appointment on your handy-dandy
calendar, take a moment to appreciate its
long and noble evolution.
The calendar so casually given to you during
the Holidays sits in your hands thanks to
the input of Egyptian priests, Julius Caesar
and co. and a Pope and his trusty Jesuit astronomer.
Bonus Fact:
On the other side of the pond, a calendar
had been devised, not unlike the one the Romans
had come up with, by a culture in Central
America called the Olmecs, and was fine tuned
around the first century AD by the Mayans.
The Mayans, having concluded that there were
365 days in a year, fashioned a calendar consisting
of 18 months including 20 days each.
They rounded out the year by adding five days
at the end which were considered to be very
unlucky.
Another aspect unique to the Mayan calendar
is what is called the “Calendar Round”,
which is a cycle lasting 52 years in which
every day has its own individual name – none
are repeated.